George Clooney is definitely having a
great time on the set of his new project
and he's talking about his twins
exclusively to eat teeth I wake up
diapers are changed they change my
diapers and then I do actually make
coffee from my wife and myself then we
actually go to work well from sleepless
nights to a knight in shining armor
it's all in a day's work for super dad
George Clooney when I was young and
lively they just put me in a suit things
have changed
only et can take you behind the scenes
of the Oscar winners third an espresso
spot about to drop in the US believe me
when you see this it's going to look
like New York like if I wish to go like
this
[Music]
it's one of only a few Nespresso
commercials a George speaks in and he
delivers his Queen Game of Thrones
one-time ruler Natalie Dormer I have
been waiting for some good honourable
night young sorry young at 57 years old
George is living his best life do you
break a party thanks to this Nespresso
contract and the sale of his cos amigos
tequila brand
he has Forbes high speed actor 2018 and
that is with out starring in a single
film now I have to pay for these
children that what I have they gotta go
to school at some point I hear I didn't
where are they going to school
George you paid enough get the coins let
him live by the way you can see George's
finished product the entire commercial
is up at EC online.com
[Music]
[Applause]